l'Europe est-elle en train de connaître
la plus grande vague migratoire de son
histoire récente en seulement 24 heures
plus de 6000 migrants sont arrivés sur
l'île de Lampedusa au sud de l'Italie a
fait savoir la Croix Rouge ce
mercredi ses déplacé arrivé par familles
entières sur environ 120 bateaux de
fortune cherchent à regagner l'Europe à
tout
prix bien que l'île de Lampedusa soit
déjà un véritable hots spot migratoire
dans la Méditerranée une telle affluence
n'a pas été observée depuis des années
sur l'île les centres d'accueil dont les
capacités n'excèdent pas les 400 places
sont totalement
débordé la police italienne a même dû
charger à plusieurs reprises pour
contenir la foule de migrants qui
demandaient à quitter le
quai preuve de la gravité de la
situation le maire de lîle Filippo
manino a décrété l'état d'urgence dans
la soirée de mercredi tout en évoquant
un nouveau drame humanitaire cet affu
chaotique a déjà fait une victime une
enfant de 5 mois est morte dans la nuit
de mardi à mercredi après être tombé à
l'eau sur X le ministre italien des
Affaires étrangères Antonio Tajani a
assuré que Rome ferait tout ce qui est
nécessaire pour aider les habitants de
Lampedusa et les migrants qui continuent
d'arriver sur
l'île pour l'heure l'urgence est de
réduire la population du site les
milliers d'arrivants seront donc
progressivement transférés vers d'autres
villes italiennes la répartition des
migrants vers les autres pays d'Europe
en vertu du mécanisme volontaire de
solidarité européen et quant à elle
source de fortes tension entre les 27 ce
mercredi l'Allemagne a notamment
suspendu jusqu'à nouvel ordre le système
d'accueil volontaire de demandeurs
d'asile en provenance d'Italie pourtant
prévu par les accords européens en
raison d'une forte pression migratoire
et de différence avec Rome Georgia
Meloni dont le parti d'extrême droite
Fratelli d'Italia a remporté les
élections législative il y a 1 an sur la
promesse de mettre un terme à
l'immigration massive à martelé mercredi
que la question de la relocalisation est
secondaire la question est d'arrêter les
arrivées en Italie nos sites d'accueil
des migrants sont pleins je ne vois
toujours pas de réponse concrète de la
part de l'Union européenne au total ce
sont environ 124000 migrants qui sont
arrivés en Italie en bateau depuis le
début de l'année selon les données du
ministère italien de l'Intérieur soit
près du double des
64529 enregistrés au cours de la même
période en 2022 plus de 2000 aurait
perdu la vie parmi eux 289
enfants